[Music]
i was sitting at my
office at general electric in valley
forge in 1970
early 74 and i got a call
and the caller said i'm calling from the
national library of medicine
and i said the national laboratory of
what
because i couldn't believe a library
would be calling me
turned out to be earl henderson who was
communications engineering branch
chief at that time here and
he described this fantastic project
linking nih and several
medical centers in the continental uh us
to remote villages in alaska
in a first ever telemedicine kind of
project and so at the time i was
designing satellites and satellite earth
terminals for
general electric and so i said well
why not you know for a year or two i'll
come down
and now it's been 43 years
i actually started at the lister hill
center
in february of 1975.
i was flying on an american airlines
flight to the west coast
and the american airlines magazine
had a cover story of arthur clark
and his 1945 paper
that suggested the possibility of
geosynchronous satellites
to be used for communications purposes
and it went on to describe and use the
name of
the lister hill national center for
biomedical communications in it
because they were conduct had been
conducting and were planning to conduct
more
satellite communications experiments for
medical purposes a lot of information
was transmitted back and forth from
health care workers
in these field sites to
professors of medicine at for example
eunice washington seattle
and also people in the universities
and at the alaskan sites could listen to
nih folks who were assembled
in the broadcast studio
that my colleague jim maine developed
here at
nlm we did thousands of hours of
teleconferencing
over satellite in many cases we had up
to five different
locations on the teleconference at the
same time
and the technology was such at that
point that
all of the things that we take for
granted now in teleconferencing
like doing face time with your iphone
all of those things had to be addressed
specifically with specific equipment
and specific technical operations
following the experimental phase the
research phase
of this project which is what it was
always intended to be
private sector took over the operation
one of the companies was western union
as i recall
and the state of alaska paid for
continuing
the project so by any kind of measure
it was an example of the government
introducing and demonstrating
a new technology and then stepping back
to allow others to take over
if you want to look at where those
satellite experiments
fall in the in the timeline
of the technology they were
unique these were a series of
communication satellites
that were the first of their kind each
one broke new technology boundaries as
we went along
and for the lister hill center to be the
primary experimenter and represent the
department of
health education and welfare in all
biomedical communications
matters it was unique and to say it was
not only the first in the country it was
first in the world because we were
obviously leaders in satellite
communications at that time
[Music]
you